skee try huh you guys have your socks
gloves long johns
check-check do you guys have your heads
okay yeast infection ointment check the
very funny guys that was funny
you guys have your ski jackets cuz we
need those yeah [ __ ] I forgot that at my
mom's house Oh Ally okay do you think
you can run and grab it and be back here
like an hour so we can leave and miss
traffic or sure you're a trip ski trip
hello hey hey yeah just want to grab my
ski jacket in the Louvre and to see your
mother ah the one who remembers
moonlight sonata and not her daughter
are you talking about the same thing
humor - defense mechanism who's this
jazz
I used to have a vest like this once I'm
just gonna get my jackets come on let's
go to the dining room tea time
you had net what reason is there to hate
you Oh a flower in a vase blooms no
different than it does in a plastic cup
love is what keeps it alive if I'm your
water will you be mine okay okay drink
all the way up there
okay smell oh I'm really sorry about
earlier I didn't know we were having
guests yes who are you dear love is what
keeps it alive
just someone who loves you very much
isn't that nice
yeah let's finish our teeth Oh